tout le monde y nerfs ça va commencer
[Musique]
c'est au sens latin baraka bras
les gouttes
si on pense fortement
et qu'on écroué aux échos c'est aussi
une formule magique car machin un petit
écran appareils faillirent bien portants
oui tu es dur commence car j'ai regardé
écrou écrou écroué peut-être encore un
écrou
cas pareil voilà et cet écho maintenant
si tu regardes bien moi je retiens
devenir pdg en place un gamin on y je
prends une petite clé à molette d'accord
l'écho qui était en métal
argenté devient maintenant doré c'est un
écho en cuivre chez du cuivre mais dis
donc t'as un regard un petit peu bizarre
où j'ai pas mal fonctionné mariage aux
différents regard magnétique alors
complètement métier à droite tu aies
jamais tu perds risque voilà c'est un
aimant kit jeunesse et pour sa
magnifique oui alors regarde enfin une
expérience très bizarre avec ses deux
écrans ah bon le premier temps un écrou
de cuivre que je sache pas comment ça va
tu parles actifs tu peux patiner avec un
libraire mais c'est pour s'alimenter je
sais coûte pas moins idiot et maintenant
le faire alors lancé nos mômes sur la
marche oui c'est terrible
des deux côtés et je fais un petit geste
sur les manques et alors là c'est
extraordinaire parce que maintenant le
faire les plus du tout est monté rien à
faire par contre là cuivre à lui
maintenant est aimanté et oui moi j'en
reviens pas bah oui et toi dis donc à
trouver ça la chirurgie un gros gros
gros gros chez moi c'est malin je t'ai
déjà dit pas jouer avec des mots il va
arriver un maximum on regarde plutôt une
expérience sérieux ça change mais bon
regarde si maintenant j'essaie d'attirer
le cuivre ou le faire
lien m'a fait ça m'a toujours pas par
contre si je fais un petit geste
et bien les deux et crouch ont pas tiré
ils sont très bien attirer pas de
problèmes comme ceux ci c'est de la
magie comme cela ils tiennent bien et si
je veux les faire tomber tout seul il
faut leur demander poliment voilà et le
ton et doit encore je me suis coincé
avec mon animal dans la fira web et à
toujours pas compris comment faire ça il
faut une formule magique y avait là
justement là la formule pour enlever les
dimensions du coût des petits lafarge
c'est plutôt une baguette magique non
si ça tu permets qu'on laporta james
volontiers lac volontiers
j'aime tout
qu'est ce à dire c'est la formule du
lapin la famille oui je note jo note la
formule tapas états voilà voilà a tenté
e à la même ça je veux rajouter ça voilà
comme ça ici ça c'est plus juste et non
une autre à la merci gérant la la
formule du lapin je sais qu'il atteint
le 2 ne faut pas eu s'agit ici le 600ème
le 6
comme ça ni ici le sait ici le la
un infini comme ça il m'a juste fait
part ici
voilà et là tout
[Musique]
jeme suis regardé le point up est là
voilà le lapin
on
aujourd'hui attention au contact du
louvre ou non nous aurons bio oui wind
jolie ronde tant qu enfin venu ghosn au
bout d'une demi roue
[Musique]
non
aux festivités
[Musique]
on
où
cette feuille de papier qui est un
mouchoir en papier à l'air magique pour
une raison simple c'est qu'elle est
vraiment magique
c'est pour regarder on en fait une
petite boulette sagesse et maintenant on
la fraude contre le bras oui factice
fera taire tout doucement
regardez bien et à force de frotter
peut-être je ne suis pas sûr d'y arriver
à n'ont rien de magique pour l'instant
mais je fais je déchire la boulette en
deux et pourtant regardez
l'une des boulettes est une feuille
entier et l'autre également et bien
l'explication acheva doublé qui voit
double alberto comme d'habitude non
regarder l'une des boulettes en vérité
depuis le départ ont été placés ici dans
les prix je vous la laisse est bien
visible
1 c'est un truc oui c'est le truc parce
que maintenant quand j'ai fait la
boulette
sous le prétexte de frotter contre mon
bras la main vient naturellement ici
donc elle peut prendre là comme ceux ci
brille dans la main l'autre bull est
secrètement ou par bh offert beaucoup de
mouvements 1
il faut bouger le moins possible m
regardez je recommence dabul était là où
la fête plus petit qu'on ne voit pas
dépenser du col on approche on apprend
tout en photo ici en vous appuyant sur
la table avec le coude
vous revenez donc votre mac contient
secrètement la boulaye vous approchez de
l'autre et vous faites semblant de
déchirer et ensuite vous pouvez les
montres est intacte vous avez bien
compris on a compris on l'accompagné et
alors il n'ya qu'une seule chose si vous
voulez faire ça faites attention papier
que vous choisissez si possible un
papier fin ou un papier qui n'était pas
trop de bruit
par exemple à papier de soie va très
bien bertrand culture ah oui mais alors
là attention parce que ce sont des
papiers soit une bande
faites attention parce qu'il se produit
deux points dans cowboys
réservez une bande de fans avoir de
galles est vraiment serré beaucoup alors
il se produit des faits un inconvénient
c'est que y en a deux non pas du tout
c'est ici
ce que la feuille devient ronde alors là
mais si vos de ma part quand vous allez
chez le papetier demandé but une feuille
de papier dont la forme ne change pas
parce qu'il ya certains papiers qui
voudront des papiers qui changea vous ne
pouvez pas faire plutôt d'accord pour
vous en souvenir
je m'en souviens fort mais revoit quand
il veut faire peur à ta famille tu tires
de ce tour et d'une présentation que tu
as trouvé tu peux nous le montrer je
prends les fantômes franc très bien qui
a peur des fantômes 3 pattes est vrai et
photos montraient pour patrice yeux ils
sont très très fragile
quand j'ai fait un boom et ils soient de
partout vraiment partout on cherche
partout sur les vues sur les murs je
l'écoulement du château bien sûr et puis
après c'est ce contraste très très fort
et est ensuite ils se déchirent
béchir lors leurs tissus et il trouve un
compagnon chantôme comme ça donc le
personnes croient qu'ils ont des enfants
tout au lieu d'un châssis vous coûteront
alors là oui et bien écoute c'est
vraiment troublant ça peut faire peur à
des gens pour la nuit surtout messi tu
perds mais je vais la faire passer le
test du fantôme pour vérifier si c'est
un vrai fantôme
regarde là je place un foulard sur la
table tu peux me prêter un goûter
fantôme alors je te rendrai peut-être
attention sur le foulard
tu vas te coucher on va l'enfermer et
maintenant vas lui tire fantôme si tu es
un vrai fantôme montre le nous un film
lol alors attention
ou alors là c'est vraiment un vrai
foutoir
et pourtant et pourtant un carton qu'est
ce qu'il ya dessous et bien non il ya
seulement le fantôme et je vous assure
que c'était une illusion car ce n'est en
fait
papier haut jura
[Musique]
oh
e
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors c'est la fin oui mais c'est la
malle à sion et maintenant j'ai un
problème je suis mais il manque une
pièce ça marche pas bien voulait que je
vienne vous chercher
bon d'accord écouter jarry un d'accord
au nom alors la ola vous c'est pas le
moment
c'est une malle à souhait tout nouvel
alors il manque quelque chose je vais
vite cherché la fille avec arrière non
non surtout vous ne touchez pas vous
êtes responsable a touché croyez vous
pas c'est sûr et puis on regarde en
cascade d'ars qui vous le regardez c'est
vite passé pour compte
[Musique]
haha mal à semer mode d'emploi pour
rappeler la personne visionne voilà je
joue avec le groenland il est constante
9,7 c'est pas les fichiers ou 39 euros
alors ça c'est pas lorsque ça c'est une
erreur de numéro
non tu as bien tout fait battant le mode
d'emploi ria belgique s'est tous
présents en belgique
free 40 00 une fois 40 00 s'est tu alors
ma musique est là où naquit ce coup là
c'est la crise à céret selanne ça va y
avait de la friture sur la ligne entre
le siècle nouveau trick regarde le mode
d'emploi
tiens la chine attend ses 36 noah chi ne
m'a aussi c'est ségolène je connais tu
connais
[Musique]
aho
alomar ou alors
c'est l'excellent attaquant pardon entre
écrire regardera ça va pas tuer bonne
mais lunettes c'est ça voilà comme ça
parce qu'en même temps et au jeu the
only chanteuse je vous ai dit que je ne
peux pas avoir confiance en eux je dis
pas toucher la touche par garde donc et
bien puisque vous êtes là
récit allez hop permet ça vous l'avez
vous allez voir ce que vous allez voir
abracadabra filles se lâchent pas on va
faire sortir tech
je ne quitte pas sa tête patrick desbois
que de politique cet événement nous
regrettons de ne pouvoir donner suite à
votre appel
[Musique]
le numéro que vous avez demandé n'est
pas en service actuellement
nous regrettons de ne pouvoir donner
suite à votre appel
à l'approché droits